and you are
great yeah come on
yes please tell us what this is about
so for the record Peter Bixby uh Dover
New Hampshire Stratford 13 a ranking
member of House i e our last uh last
fall we did a study uh study committee
on soil conditioners and one of the
things that director Wyman uh spoke
about when he was testifying was that uh
they weren't actually able to test
fertilizer Beyond a couple of uh tests
that they did on complaint because their
staff time was so occupied with doing
data entry they receive all of their
registration forms which are quite there
are a lot of them and Licensing forms
um
on paper and then they enter them into
spreadsheets like 1980s style
spreadsheets uh and uh this obviously
wastes a lot of Staff time and uh the uh
the lack of Technology also makes it
more difficult for people who want to
interact with the Department you can't
just fill out a form online saying
please update my registration for x and
such fertilizer you have to fill it out
all on paper and mail it in uh and uh
that's you bad in terms of our
relationships with the public that we
are uh uh working on regulating and the
idea behind fertilizer regulation is
that you want to make sure that if
someone says that they are providing say
5 10 5 on the label then you want to
make sure that it actually contains that
and you want to have a representative
sample that tested every year
so I initially wrote A bill that would
provide data processing for the
um for the fertilizer statute and uh the
department came back and said actually
we have this problem in all of our
divisions and we should just have
something department-wide that will
allow us to do data data processing in a
manner consistent with it being in the
2020s rather than the on 1980s uh so
are they because we had we passed an the
animal database Bill a couple years ago
there's actually now an I.T person
dedicated to uh to the Department of
Agriculture and that person was able to
provide uh some numbers for what uh this
processing system would cost and also if
they go with the same vendor it will
create efficiencies uh so
um it looks like the cost is going to be
well last fall he quoted 360
000 uh the fiscal note says between 360
and 500 000 and given the uh and then a
2002 2000 200 000 for
um every year for maintenance thereafter
that maintenance can be covered by
existing fees uh so uh what we just need
is the capital expense to get it started
and the return on investment for this is
going to be huge and basically we're
going to be saving several staff
positions by or or there would need we
there would need to be more staff
positions to actually execute the law if
this doesn't go through so um so it's a
basically it's a good
um
it's a good investment and I'm happy to
take questions
for Representatives
no all right yes representative Griffin
thank you for taking the question
and thank you for answering it if you
can
there's a lot of federal money around
opco money and all the money around has
anybody done any research this seems
like the type thing that is agriculture
and it seems like the type thing where
you might just stumble onto a uh a
perfect fit with money that's already
been appropriated from the federal
government
on their
we haven't looked at that and because
this is really an operating expense I
think it would be a pretty low priority
in terms of a Grant application uh so
um I so as far as I know it has not been
looked at I did mention it to the
governor and uh he sounded like he
thought that it was an interesting
problem and that we do have a budget
surplus at this point and that and I
know that the governor prefers to use
budget surpluses for one-time expenses
this this is a one-time expense so it
would be a good fit for that
yes representative cameras thank you Mr
chair um you mentioned that uh it would
the if you got this it would prevent
having to hire additional staff would it
cut any in uh staff that exists today I
I don't believe that it would cause any
staff Cuts because essentially they
hired the staff so to be able to do
things like fertilizer assessment so
you're doing the determination of
whether there's actually the right
amount of nitrogen and potassium and Etc
in it so and to uh and also to be able
to work with the regulatory issues
around that uh and those staff are being
used simply for data entry now they
would be returned to doing what they're
actually supposed to be doing under the
law
I mean not uh representative
what happens if if one of these things
that says it's 10 nitrogen and it's only
six
can you go and Trace them down in every
store that's selling this yes uh there
is a uh so the uh the fertilizer is
registered by the manufacturer and uh
and the manufacturer labels it with
what's supposed to be in it and the
manufacturer has a list of uh stores
that they sell to and or to or Farms
that they sell to if they sell directly
and there is a um
there is a procedure in law for what to
do about deficiencies uh the penalties
for those deficiencies have actually
just been or the pro that process has
just been updated by something we passed
on the consent calendar
um a couple of weeks ago so it isn't
just something that sits there and says
oh sorry they actually go and remove
these from right so distribution so the
so they remove it gets removed from
distribution and anyone who uh purchased
it is entitled to a refund under current
law if they purchased over a ton uh with
the bill that we passed a few weeks ago
is going to be anybody
okay
is New Hampshire
agricultural law somehow unique or is
this likely that some other state has
software that that would be adequate for
this purpose uh the
um so the the
software will be necessary uh would be
basically there there is a vendor that
that the department would work with
because it it's essentially it's going
to be everything that the department
does it's not it the vendor would not be
solving a new problem
but the but you but having a vendor is
going to be a much more cost effective
way of doing it than trying to do it
in-house with
um given our
the way that Tech it is set up in New
Hampshire
so uh
I'm sure that the the vendor is likely
I'm I don't know this for a fact but
this is going to be our RFP going out
the people who the vendors likely to be
responding to that RFP will be people
who are
used to doing this sort of system and uh
it's a matter of making sure that the
when you're talking about you know can
you feel a fill a form out online and
send it in and have it appear online in
in a workable manner in a database
that's not something that's specific to
New Hampshire law that's like
as I'm sure you're aware
thank you any further questions for
representative so another thing about
this is that in terms of is is New
Hampshire unique in terms of the law
there's a
um there's a
National Organization that looks to
standardize laws in New Hampshire law is
basically consistent with that
so we have someone else here would like
to
weigh in on this
please state your name and spell it if
it's difficult thank you chairman
Maguire and thank you to all of you my
name is Sherry Gould I think that's
pretty straightforward but s-a-g-r-ry
like the wine g-o-u-l-d and I represent
Merrimack District eight uh Warner
Bradford in hanager so um I'm here for
the Edna committee we heard the bill and
um we passed it uh overwhelmingly out
and it passed on the floor so this bill
will update the Department of
Agriculture from paper to online
procedures relieving employees who are
spending time on administrative data
entry freeing them for data collection
and verification will allow the
department to fulfill its required
duties more effectively the department
will move ahead with the support of the
Department of Information Technology to
contract development of an electronic
system that will replace some old and
unsupported data collection systems such
as the important weights and measures
data system and add the elements to
modernize the systems as the department
is funded by fees the costs associated
with the bill appeared to us to be
reasonable to remedy the tremendous need
fully recognizing and supporting that
you all decide the fiscal matter is we
decide the policy matters
I was particularly struck with the
commissioner's report that the weights
and measures data system was developed
in the 1980s by a prisoner who has since
been released and fulfilled his time and
so we have no support for that system
and it's failing and the commissioner
was concerned will it even last if we
get this put through so I think what
representative Bixby reported to you is
important but that's one just one piece
of the broader picture that's really
important and weights and measures
govern so much of our income for the
state
so you're saying that this is more than
just for fertilizer this is for all the
other operations in the department yes
yes everything and that's part of why
the contractor will be coordinating that
all with the I.T person who's embedded
in the Department of Agriculture was
there uh giving testimony to the
committee and he felt very confident
that the breadth and the need would be
covered that he understands the
processes better and that this should go
well
thank you other questions for
representative Gould
all right see now okay
let me just redirect him to
representative Bixby you agree with what
she just said that
way
um
thank you very much
oh yes uh representative hatch
please come back representative
and turn on your mic representative
are we still using
um individuals to uh private contractors
to check the measuring system as opposed
to
we used to have our own Department that
oversaw weights and measures how is that
accomplished that is uh that's done by
contract and so it does not it is that
it is done with contractors so so for
instance
um for uh testing the um the accuracy of
gas pumps
um there are contractors who uh who are
who do that to do the testing and then
there is a auditing process that the
department has to make sure that they do
a spot check on uh the work that the
contractors have done and make sure that
they are doing that correctly and
there's no if I may and there's no
issues with um having this coordinating
this system with the contractor as
opposed to as opposed to what they have
now is that done in cooperation with
them or in conjunction with them or I uh
I don't know the actual process uh
that the contractors would use for
reporting but I assume that the
contractors would be much happier to uh
just upload their information as opposed
to having to fill out a paid perform and
send it in
okay thank you thank you Mr chair you're
welcome all right thank you very much is
there anyone else here oh dude no okay
did anyone else here who would like to
weigh in on House Bill 230.
no okay so what do I do close the here
or we'd start talking discuss it maybe
any discussion um
we have agriculture coming in this
afternoon so we might want to talk about
it with the commissioner see whether we
should put it in his budget or what we'd
like to do with it so
representative Griffin
thank you uh could I make a general
comment we have a series of bills before
us most the reason they're here is they
all have a fiscal point
a fiscal impact
and I'm thinking that um
that
the economy may not be as healthy as
the governor anticipate it it is being
and we haven't had any feedback from
Ways and Means yet to my knowledge
so I hope that
we hold these bills until we have a
better feeling
on what monies are available
sounds wise to me
that's my plan representative Griffin
I'll see we have 10 minutes you must
have done a good job representative yeah
he didn't ask any questions
[Laughter]
but we're going to see him later yeah 2
30 or 2 o'clock I believe yeah
all right thank you
all right we have 10 minutes
now we can catch up
we got about two and a half I saw a lot
in the back of your truck
American time yeah so so representative
Sweeney asked about procedure so my
guess is if the bill looks right it
doesn't need any Amendment right then um
presumably and it's just about spending
money or not then then we would retain
it typically right and then when we get
to the to our our quote our numbers in
the budget right uh we did you know we
make a decision is this worthy to be
over the line and be funded or under the
line and not be funded right you know
where does this the importance of this
compared to everything else in the
budget right
um but if and and and and then assuming
we decide to fund it the numbers would
go into house bill one and the the body
of the bill will go into house bill too
right but if
um
let's say the bill itself
needed let's say like house bill 50
where we change the bill completely
right we changed it from spending money
in one way to spending money in another
way I would assume with a bill like that
we would send it back to the house in
the new form assuming the rest of the
committee likes it and then assuming the
house passes it we would then ask the
house to table it at that moment right
after being passed and then we would
come back and do the same thing about
putting it in the budget or not you know
et cetera is that correct yeah yes
and you know it the point is normally we
know how much money we can spend before
we get the budget for some reason we
haven't found that figure yet
you know the the governor has all these
ambitious spending plans but
the revenue he shows is a little less
so
I spoke to representative Sanborn the
other day and she said they're not even
going to be coming up with those numbers
until next week so it's like the end of
next week maybe or something like that
you know
so represent Griffin if I can add
something for the newer members we never
know where we're going to be
and as we go through these departments
everybody should be looking for areas
that in a worst case scenario if we had
to make cuts
looking for those areas that would be
logical cuts and keeping track of them
because I've been on the committee
before where at the end of the session
they say okay we've got to find 10
million dollars
and you know if you if if if you're
trying to do it in retrospect it doesn't
work if if you've been keeping track
along the areas of the budget that are
weak
then you're in a position office and
some True Cuts that won't hurt too much
I just learned today that house bill 2
is like 500 pages
and most of it's oplc stuff
yeah
but no we don't have it yet another
point is when a bill comes to us well
supported it's past the house it's got a
good vote
I'm reluctant to say no we're not going
to fund it you know especially if it's
small money like this it's under a
million dollars
we can very likely something like this
it's not a problem but you know if
something comes in with a huge amount of
money that that's kind of a Target but
and especially if it's struggled to get
through the house but
you know
we have to realize and there are other
things we can look at
like in the past
there was one that came to Western that
said we need to hire three more
inspectors to do something
and I would go to the committee and I'd
say
are all the inspectors in this
department busy or can you change some
of them over to do this job rather than
hiring three new people isn't there some
place within the organization that you
don't need three people then we can
re-substitute them for this and it makes
it a lot easier but it's a conversation
we have to have sometimes thanks
representative evil right on time but we
have a few minutes
your written testimony was very good I
don't know if the members all saw that
or if you have printed copies for
foreign
so we'll open up the work session on
House Bill 300 as soon as representative
ebels finished passing out some earlier
written testimony we'll let her
speak to any questions there might be
good morning Mr chair and uh and
committee members so
um you have before you
um HB 300 which just passed the house uh
on a Voice vote it was recommended uh
20-0 by the environment and agriculture
committee it has a great deal of
bipartisan support and
um it is a bill that attempts to get the
state of New Hampshire a little bit more
on track with its solid waste so what I
thought I would do is I'll um
I'll describe the bill but it's really
kind of
um
hard to fully uh to fully understand
what we're trying to do unless I give
you a little bit of context which is
what I try to do in the written
testimony that I did for you
so basically what HB 300 would do it
would ban the generators of food waste
of one ton or more a week from disposing
the food waste in a landfill or an
incinerator but only if there was a
place that could handle the food waste
within 20 miles of the entity generating
the waist
um
so
the food waste generally would have to
be separated and the Order of preference
for for
diverting it would be a reduction would
be to start out with trying to generate
less food waste in the beginning try to
get it out for human consumption try to
get it out for animals for farms and
then the last thing as appropriate you
could use it for composting you could
use it for anaerobic digestion or if
appropriate land application and then
you could also use it for energy
recovery the effective date would be two
years from now give or take on February
1st 2025
so
um
in updating my testimony I still say
here that it's a 50 mile radius that was
amended so it's a 20 mile radius so I
apologize for that
um per the EPA statistics it's it's uh
and it is estimated that approximately
25 in weight of all the
um waste that we put into our landfills
is food waste and this
um one ton ban would be a really good
way of trying to get that waste out of
our landfills and also trying to get
food to the hungry so as a result of
this bill there's also been a great deal
of Interest among Food Bank folks and
there's also been a great deal of
Interest among businesses that are
interested in doing composting
and also
agricultural folks who want to do
composting on their Farms this started
really for me this journey in 2019 when
you may recall the Chinese decided that
they weren't going to take our Plastics
and our mixed paper anymore and our
municipalities were really really
floundering on what to do with their
waste their um they were as you may know
the when when you dispose of your Solid
Waste when it goes to a landfill or an
incinerator you're paying a per ton
charge so the more waste you have
obviously the more your costs are going
to be for tipping fees so many of these
municipalities were faced with a
situation that instead of getting income
for their recyclables
um through the the Chinese venue they
were floundering with respect to their
costs with um with increased tipping
fees
so I uh
introduced a bill and we had a
legislative study committee and we had
14 hearings in about I'd say six weeks
we had 50 stakeholders I tried to bring
in everybody from like everything that I
can think of from landfill operators
agricultural folks municipalities any
number of folks and I would say it
started sort of a voyage of Discovery
and understanding that we really haven't
been paying attention to our Solid Waste
situation in the state for decades
the long-range Solid Waste plan that we
had hadn't been updated since 2003 we
had diversion goals and when I talk
about diversion goals what I'm trying to
express is that you're trying to divert
the trash from going into the landfills
so our diversion goals went back to the
90s and they were supposed to be
achieved by 2000 they had not been
updated
um uh in the situation with the
municipalities trying to deal with these
roiling Global markets
Des really wasn't able to support them
very much and so when we were sitting
there listening we found out that Des
used to have a planning department and
due to budget cuts they had no planning
department whatsoever anymore
and so they really weren't able to help
the towns they weren't able to help the
state
and the solid waste Bureau had really
been I would say pretty much decimated
so basically our bipartisan group tried
to come up with several things to
achieve and I'm actually really pleased
with the progress that we've made
because if you look at this we're sort
of starting from the the ground up
trying to rebuild the situation in the
state and the first thing we did was we
renewed and updated our Solid Waste
Disposal uh diversion goals and we're
going to try to achieve a 25 reduction
by 2030 and a 45 reduction by 2050 we do
have we passed a bill that put a
deadline on it and we do have a new
long-range Solid Waste Management plan
we created a solid waste working group
that would work hand in hand with des
and development of that plan I chair
that
um that group and through some
reorganization Within the solid waste
Bureau we do have a couple of folks that
are now helping with planning but
they're the ones that you know they help
with all the legislative support and
um and now they're going to be tasks
with making the solid waste plan a
reality
but to make that uh plan a reality we
have to act on some of the goals that
are set forth in it and so uh to do that
it will take some investment by the
state to sort of come back from where we
were 30 years ago and this is all really
important because all our uh region the
Northeast region is very aggressively uh
trying to reduce what they're putting
into their landfills and um and taking
real bold action to try to do better and
basically we haven't done much of
anything for years except that we have
landfills
um and some of the states are now
sending their trash to New Hampshire as
they progressively reduce the number of
landfills in their own State
I think you all know by now that under
the interstate commerce clause there
really isn't any way to ban out of state
waste from coming into our state
but what we can do is do some things to
protect our our capacity for landfilling
and also do better with
um with solid waste so
in going through the goals of the solid
waste plan and trying to understand some
low-hanging fruit if you'll forgive the
phrase one of the things that we
identified that all the region is doing
is initiating a food waste ban for one
ton or more and I guess the only thing I
would other thing that I would add here
is that we do have other bands in place
that we have lived with we don't allow
for instance leaf and yard waste to go
into our into our landfills
um
I could talk about this for a really
long time but I just I want to add one
thing and that is that landfills when
they're permitted there's a lot more to
it but they are based on volume and so
you know if you go to a landfill you see
these
machines with you know Wheels as high as
the ceiling and they're compacting
compacting and packing and
um you know if you're trying to preserve
your landfill capacity you should be
looking for things that make sense to
not put in landfills
that we can put far better use to so um
in the state you know landfills is the
least desirable way of dealing with our
um waste and I think in the long run we
should be able to
um save money I can talk about landfill
leachate I can talk about toxic
chemicals I can talk about all those
things I think we have to recognize
whatever goes into a landfill it stays
there it's not busily degrading because
it's an anaerobic kind of a situation
but the water comes through the
landfills collect the leachate it goes
to our wastewater treatment plants we
can talk about pfas we can talk about
all the unbelievable amount of money
we're dealing with at the wastewater
treatment plant size so I'm trying to
change the conversation a little bit and
trying to get people to focus on where a
lot of this plate stuff is coming from
so
with that I'd be happy to talk to the
committee about it
any questions for representative evil
representative Griffin
I'd like to know
hmm
who would be the typical
business or
type entity that would be subject to
this in other words it's a restaurant
with 250
seeds generating that much waste would
they be subject to it is my local
supermarket subject to it
Etc well one of the ways
one of the things that really helped me
personally Envision this I I talked to
somebody that collects food waste they
said it's
eight to ten
eight to ten 64 gallon totes that are
filled to capacity and they have
200 to 250 pounds per tote so that's
what a that's basically what a ton is
um
the the folks that would well first of
all I should say there was no objection
at the hearing nobody really came forth
I think it would involve hospitals it
would involve very large Grocers and it
could uh involve very large restaurants
the thing that I want to point out is
that this isn't like a cumulative thing
it's not like if there's a McDonald's if
they generate a ton
at 10 you know taken all together at 10
restaurants that's not what this is this
is individual generators
um so I talked to a Hannafords for
instance in my area and what they're
doing and this is an initiative that
comes from Maine
Hannaford has a contract with a company
called agricycle and agricycle runs an
anaerobic digester that produces energy
in Maine and they go around to all the
Hannafords they collect all the food
waste that goes into the totes
including packaged you know the the the
um the the grocery stores aren't
required to de-package their stuff
everything just gets dumped in and then
agricults it and then they take it to
Maine to um to run their their
digester and the other thing though that
I mean I I wasn't thinking about this
exactly sorry I'm stemming from I'm
veering from your question but the folks
that are affected by this say a grocery
store like Hannaford they're working
real you know they would work closely
with food banks and food banks are
really excited about this to get more
food to feed the hungry which let's face
it is where food should be going not
into our dumps
I guess I'm what I'm looking for is uh
statistics on how much food waste is
generated by different types of entities
and apparently you don't have any of
that well uh Des is here I'm not sure
what they what they have exactly
statistically
um what I can tell you and this isn't
exactly an answer to you but what I can
tell you is that Des estimated that
approximately 190 tons of food waste
could be diverted from our landfills if
this went into
um into place
representative Weiler thank you Mr
chairman
so I've been making compost for decades
and I use a shredder
and when you put food waste in it
there's a lot of liquid in it and it
makes a mess if you don't mix something
in it so I always have a supply of
either Christmas tree branches or or dry
leaves and it and it comes out dry and
then I soak it and it composts very
nicely
so I'm looking at grocery stores which
create tons of cardboard
and if they shredded the cardboard and
then mixed that with the food waste so
that they could have something dry so
that the liquid would be absorbed and I
wonder if anybody has tried that as an
experiment I would think the the
cardboard shredded cardboard would be an
ideal thing and it's it's it's killed
two birds with one stone I wonder if
anybody's tried that as an experiment it
seems to me obvious with a grocery store
um I can't tell you exactly but I've
been in places where they have separate
bins for
compost and they tell you to put in Old
Kleenex and you know like
um paper towels and things like that and
I'm sure that you know I can't speak for
an anaerobic digester operator but I I
would think that as an organic substance
paper products could be used in some way
and and they could be used to they they
generate electricity so it's really
um
I think this is a really nice meshing
between preserving our landfill capacity
doing better with food waste and also
providing business opportunities for
people who are really interested in this
sort of thing it's a and and I've talked
to Vermont and some of these other
states and things just sort of evolve
together
and I I just want to point out that
someone you know if you were subject to
this ban as an institution unless there
was a recipient for the food waste
within 20 miles you wouldn't have to do
it
represent McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming to our community
happy to be here
um
do you know how many tons per week of of
all waste is both generated in New
Hampshire and comes to New Hampshire for
Mother's Day I'm going to leave that
question to Des which is behind me what
I what I do know is what's going into
our landfills is approximately 2 million
tons annually and about half of that is
is out of state and just to clarify on
your vid on your Voyage of solid waste
with me there are private landfills in
the state and there are public landfills
in the state and public landfills can
either be owned Say by Nashua or they
can be a solid waste District that are
owned by multiple municipalities and
it's really the municipalities right to
you know they they limit it to the
people that they're serving private
companies can take their waste from
from us obviously but from out of state
or whatever so it's really the private
landfills that are the ones that are
mostly taking the out of state waste
so in my town we have mandatory
recycling so we separate out
aluminum tin cardboard paper
plastic and glass and then the rest is
trash right so when you say this could
say 2 million annually is that all those
categories or is that just the one that
I would call trash
well I don't think I would I said it
would save two million no no that's the
total in the total but um
so
yeah so I'm gonna see what Des says
about this so but when they're
calculating I think how much uh waste is
generated they're talking across all
categories
um
and then they have statistics that they
get on the different subsets
thank you
so a fiscal question yes
it shows one additional employee I
believe starting in 25 is there any
reason the Department of Environmental
Services didn't include this in their
budget why this is a standalone build
because kind of curious
um I think when they were developing
their budget during the governor's phase
um
and I have to be honest I'm not exactly
sure when that was but that was when the
solid waste management plan it wasn't
issued until November of 20
22 and then the solid waste working
group was reviewing the plan and trying
to develop its goals and so
I mean all of these things took place a
little bit later so it could that could
be why
um it wasn't included but I think that
um
I think that the I think that the
department I don't want to speak for the
department but I think that they pretty
much um
they did the efficiency budget I'm not
sure how much more they would have added
on I just like to
yes so this is new policy right right
they're not currently required to uh
divert food Etc so the extra person is
to make sure they do right right so you
can't put it in the budget until you
know it until this policy is law right
right yeah so but but I think just it's
expand from that
um I
I'd like to suggest that this bill be
retained and be part of a broader
conversation about the solid waste
Bureau and a broader conversation about
the planning department because
we have a we now have a solid waste
management plan we haven't had one since
2003 we haven't really had clear-cut
goals to pursue
we haven't been surrounded by states
that are very aggressively trying to do
better with their solid waste and you
know the discussion about landfills is
obviously roiling our state and we have
to on I mean I just think we have to
rebuild the solid waste Bureau from
where it was we've got to start we've
got a plan and we can just really dig in
now and and and do better with these
issues
um
I've really become a Believer I have to
say I've never been engaged with the
subject quite so much which I understood
involved every single individual every
single business I mean it just we all
consume things and we all throw things
away and I think it's time that we think
a little bit better about how we're
managing it
um so I I really
I look forward to talking with the
division a little bit more on this and
um and I hope we can make this a reality
I hope that um
we help Des do better for our for our
talents and our businesses and our
people in the state
representative kimbrells thank you Mr
chair it's the bill implies that if
there are no uh facilities that can
handle the waste within 20 miles then
there's then the generator generator is
exempt that's right okay and um
to your knowledge
um how many of these type of facilities
do we have around the state
would there be one located within 20
miles of a lot of places presumably or
there wouldn't be there wouldn't be and
you know this obviously I mean I think
you run into this a lot when you try to
do an initiative like this it's a little
bit of a chicken and egg situation but I
can tell and I don't know who you want
to call the chicken and who you want to
call the egg but I can tell you there
are some business chickens that are
really interested in sharing some of
these eggs
and follow up Mr chair
uh and in in terms of the other states
that have already done this and have
some experience who's who's enforcing it
or how are they enforcing it and are
there any penalties handed out to these
businesses if they don't comply
[Music]
I've talked to
certificates of compliance and they I
mean they just do a procedure I think
it's a pretty light touch I don't think
anybody is going in there smashing eggs
on anybody's heads but to continue the
metaphor
um but
I mean
uh on our let me put it this way on our
Solid Waste working group we have a
representative of uh private landfill
public landfill
hospitals
retailers small towns Big Towns the Bea
everybody that I could I mean that would
make sense and
in identifying a really good way of
starting to achieve our goals and saving
our landfill space this was the one that
we identified as a great place to start
follow-up question
you all said
so going back to my fiscal question okay
if you look at the original
language under 149 M27 is refuse
reduction and you're adding the
prohibition of food waste
is there somewhere now that's embedded
in the department that's doing the
reduction oversight
um I'm gonna leave that to Des but in
their reorganization I just
in their reorganization let's just they
did not have a planning department and
because of all these initiatives that
that we've been pushing forward as a
legislature and I will say
virtually unanimously
the reorg has taken
one person that I think was in
permitting and they have now a planning
department and they have one up so they
have two people and I believe they call
it the planning and waste reduction
section and they can tell you more about
that but yes I mean that's their
that's what they're going to be
dedicating themselves to
see no further questions for
representative evil will ask the Des to
quickly come forward and
explain your position whatever it might
be and if you could state your name for
the record as well
uh thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael Nork I am
representing the solid waste management
Bureau at New Hampshire Des
and I believe that representative evil
provided you a copy of our letter of
testimony for the bill when it was in
hearing before Ena we are not taking a
position on the bill per se although we
do think that the concept has Merit one
of the concerns that we had identified
in the original hearing was that
additional Personnel requirement to
fully carry out and robustly enforce the
uh the new policy that this would
implement but that being said this is a
policy that is in place in other states
it is actually very closely modeled
after the state of Vermont and how they
started out their food waste disposal
ban
um so there are models where we we see
this working
um and we think that you know if Des
were to
fully uh carry out this responsibility
we would want to do it in a workman-like
way uh which is why we would we would
need that additional position
um I can I took some notes on some of
the questions that were asked I don't
know if you would if that would be
helpful for me to try to address some of
the the questions uh that the committee
raised already
okay
uh so uh
there was a question about
the most recent question about the the
section in the statute that references
refuse reduction I believe the bill
amends that to say disposal prohibited
if you actually look at that section of
the statue it's titled refuse reduction
which is kind of an erroneous title um
so I think the bill is trying to correct
that because the other sections or the
other provisions of that
uh of m20149 M27 talk about not
disposing leaf and yard waste in the in
landfills not disposing of a wet cell
like automotive batteries
um so it's just trying to to clear that
up and make it a little bit clearer in
the statute that in fact that section is
more about prohibiting disposal in a
landfill or an incinerator
um and I think representative people did
a good job of answering a question of
who is currently carrying out uh issues
related to uh you know disposal and and
reducing the amount of waste that we
dispose of that is in fact myself along
with Paige Wilson who is sitting behind
me so we are the the cohort within the
solid waste management Bureau that we
call ourselves the materials management
education and planning section so we are
the kind of the the section that was
resurrected after many years of of lack
of attention at DES to Solid Waste
Management planning and uh waste
reduction recycling you know more more
of the we have a hierarchy in the state
waste disposal hierarchy and that's what
our section is trying to help uphold you
know things that are more preferable
than just landfilling and incinerating
um
representative cambrell's you asked
about uh how many facilities currently
exist that would be able to uh fulfill
the need that this ban would would put
in place uh currently there are I think
I don't have the exact numbers but I
think right around 10 or 12 permitted
composting facilities in the state but
the the way the bill is structured there
are other
facilities that could also help like
representative was was mentioning Food
donation uh you know so there's kind of
a panoply of different facilities that
could help fulfill this ban
um
and the other thing is and this is how
other states have implemented it they
delay the actual effective date so that
it gives it sends a signal to the
um to the industry that that wants to
start composting facilities or anaerobic
digestion facilities or Food donation
networks by putting a law in place and
having a delayed implementation it sends
that signal and allows them time to
develop that infrastructure that would
be necessary so that I think that was
kind of contemplated in how this bill
was structured as well gives a two-year
kind of DeLay So that folks are aware
that this is coming and that they can
adapt and have time to do that
um representative McGuire asked about uh
tonnage uh on a weekly basis we don't
have the exact numbers broken down by
week but representative evil was correct
that if you just look at what's disposed
of in New Hampshire and in our landfills
and incinerators it is about 2 million
tons uh annually about half of that
comes from New Hampshire the other half
comes from out of state so if you take 1
million which is half of 2 million and
break that down uh over the course of
the year it's roughly 20 000 tons just
doing back of them and back of the
napkin kind of calculation
um
Des did some rough calculations to try
to figure out how much food waste is
generated in the state we think we're
just using some some estimates from the
EPA but we think that according to the
if the EPA estimate holds true for New
Hampshire it's probably around 180 or
190 000 tons per year so this is a
significant portion of the waste stream
um you know if
if we generate collectively around 1
million tons
um you know 200 000 tons is is a is a
pretty good chunk of that about 20 or so
um so those are some of the the
questions that I had um oh there was a
question about how do you estimate I
think it was representative Griffin
um how do you estimate
who would be subject to the ban
um what other states have done is
they've actually developed
um through research with an organization
called the the center for Eco technology
they've created a sector by sector
different estimators for how much food
waste a particular kind of business
entity might generate so a lot of states
have actually leaned on this it's it's a
it's a basically a compendium of
different uh businesses like restaurants
hotels grocery stores based on square
footage based on number of employees to
help kind of narrow down who might be
subject to the ban and that's what a lot
of other states have have leaned on that
kind of research
representative Griffin
is that available to us do you have a
copy that I can make that available yeah
I'll do a little research when I get
back to the office there is a website I
believe that um
if the testimony that I distributed
yesterday there's a link link to the
estimator site right so if you get the
digital version you can click on it and
it'll get you to the estimator
right representative McGuire thank you
Mr chairman I wanted to ask about this
out of state issue at the bottom of the
letter from Des it lists a bunch of
states that have this representative
Ebel implied that the state of Maine has
this but but the main is not on this
list
so so there Hannaford in Maine is doing
this on their own not because they're
required I see that's all right let me
asking so
um if a grocery store in Massachusetts
was sending its ways to New Hampshire I
assume this ban would start to apply to
it yes
that's not clear to me
um I think the way the bill and I think
I see representative
comes off
I mean yes that's that's kind of the
point you know because we want to have
an across-the-board ban that applies not
just to us but to the the out of state
depositors of trash in our landfills
okay so as a follow-up when you're
enforcing it the 20 miles you would have
to know this Grocery Store in
Massachusetts what's going on within 20
miles of them
not just what's going on in New
Hampshire right in order to to enforce
this correctly I guess is that it's a
it's a good question I think our
jurisdiction would really be within the
state of New Hampshire I think it would
be a little bit of a
a stretch for us to start regulating
entities outside of the state borders
but what we can regulate are the
facilities in New Hampshire
so so if it is waste that's going to a
landfill that is banned from disposal at
that landfill that's that's where we can
regulate so we have jurisdiction over
the facilities that we permit in the
state
um you know if it's a disposal facility
or whatever we do have jurisdiction over
that but the generator itself I think
it's a little questionable I'm not a
lawyer and I'm not sure if how how to to
Really interpret the language of the
statuteness or if this were to be
adopted in statute but it just in
general I think our jurisdiction is
pretty clearly within the state of New
Hampshire
all right I'll save the rest for
discussions
so I hopefully have a quick question for
you on your support from the Department
you said primarily your support was
because of the cost factor I guess
hiring somebody
it would appear if it's a worthwhile
program
um
and if the money was there you would
support this legislation
um I I can't speak for the Department
necessarily I think
um
as a as a general rule I think we are
just not taking a position on this bill
as a you know as a policy but we did
want to voice Our concern about the cost
that would be necessary just to be you
know sure that we were considering that
if it was to be implemented and I guess
just to clearly answer your question I
can't say whether we would support like
clearly support the bill if that was to
come to fruition
okay thanks
see no further questions thank you thank
you
so uh well obviously we'll hold on to
this as well
so moving right along I see a
representative Merchant here I would
assume you're here to speak on House
Bill 337
if you could come forward and take the
mic and identify yourself for the record
welcome to division one
thank you Mr
for the record my name is Gary Merchant
representative
and representing Sullivan district 6
which is Claremont and Croydon I come
before you today
in regards to House Bill 337 which was
heard by the policy committee and passed
that committee
during the hearing
there was a mistake made in the drafting
of a bill which created a fiscal note
which you see before you
and subsequently we modified that bill
to reduce the need for the physical note
and I don't see
director Courtney here but my
understanding is in the testimony
during the time it was being heard along
the amendment
that that basically either reduced or
almost eliminated the need for the
fiscal note
so
I don't have an email from her per se I
think you folks they want to go back and
revisit that fiscal note and ask her to
have it be trapped it or redone
but the intent of the bill before we get
into the finance is the policy side of
it what we heard during the summer I was
sitting on a committee
to look at oplc
and one of the things that was heard
time and time again
was the issue of
notices of meetings the ability to have
documents like you folks have before you
today
for those documents to be shared with
the public prior to the meeting itself
so the bill fundamentally
enhances the right to know our
government is based upon transparency
it's a foundation of democracy
and when you have boards which have
regulatory Authority
and they don't notice the meetings
sufficiently enough a lot of people who
are professionals
don't have the ability in their work
schedule
within 24 to 48 hours to take a day off
they have to schedule the time so in
order to accomplish that or to
accommodate that
what we ask for is the notice be posted
two weeks before the meeting
we also want to be sure that the
documents
that are being shared by the board
are available to the public
so when the board is discussing the
documents the people in the audience
the ones that they regulate or the
public itself understand what the
conversation is all about so that was
the intent of the bill
I did work with director Courtney we
modified the
reason for the fiscal note
we also went back and she drafted
something to be sure it wasn't in
violation of 91a because her concern
which I totally support
there'd be
possible times in which the documents
need to be protected for whatever reason
so it could be going through an
application for a licensure
so as long as the documents do not
violate 91a
they should be made available publicly
that's the intent of the bill and I'll
send you my testimony I didn't want to
read it to you verbatim I think you can
probably read it as well as I can but
I'll send it to you folks
as soon as I'm done with the meeting I
should have brought copies with you I
apologize
oh no apology necessary we you probably
saved us some work and we try to stick
to the fiscal impact of legislation so
you're telling us you don't see any
physical impact now but again we just
work with what we've received and it
shows a physical impact of over three
hundred thousand dollars correct a year
so I guess we'll have to wait for a new
fiscal note Mr Hoffman have we heard
anything or Melissa
all right so nothing nothing new out
there yet then we don't have anything
new okay thanks Mr chairman who who is
the one that triggers the review of the
fiscal note because I talked to director
Courtney this morning when the amendment
went through there was no request for
the fiscal note to be revised she would
reach out to the legislative budget
Assistance office and they would get
that fiscal note or lack thereof to us
uh procedural question if the fiscal
note comes back
basically zero you can build is
basically basically that point in time
be vacated or do you still have to vote
on it well we would still vote on it but
we would know to the full committee
there's no fiscal loan so we'd probably
say in the committee report we found no
fiscal impact okay
all right that's my testimony for this
morning are there any questions of
of Representative Merchant you don't
have one oh I know no
this is more of a statement but I heard
the same thing from Carol that
representative Merchant said that that
it was an error and and therefore they
changed it so that to get rid of the
money out of the bill so
thanks very much for your attendance
today thank you Mr chairman
yes sir you have a a question for us or
good morning if you could share your
name for us my name is Douglas osterhau
I am general counsel for the office of
professional licensure and certification
uh we did not receive a fiscal note
worksheet request for this third Bill
I'd be happy to put one together if if
the committee did So like
um I'm really just here to observe and
answer any questions anyone might have I
did draft the fiscal note worksheet on
the first
two iterations of the bill
kept hopping around
if you could again get together with
Melissa or Mike Hoffman and get that
revised fiscal note that would be great
absolutely thank you other questions
oh and could you spell your yeah a
cardio spell your last name that card is
good
I should say it's slower too osterhout
OST e r h o u d t pronounced exactly as
it's spelled except for the silent
letters
all right thank you very much
Carol uh I'm sorry representative
McGuire your husband has like 10 minutes
so you could spend with him
all right we'll take a uh
all right nice to see you representative
McGuire
will take a 12 minute break
let's go
yeah we my dad is fighting all my cancer
but it seems to be a remission but his
uh red blood cells are off and we went
down we brought like 100 200 plus worth
of four because he missed layout enroll
was a way there's no stores nearby
thank you
all right we'll open the work session on
House Bill
347 establishing a superior land use
review docket and I have to say I'm very
disappointed that this representative
does not still serve on finance but we
are you are a Miss sir well thank you
and I have to say I miss you guys too I
really had it was uh there was a a tough
choice because I really enjoyed working
on finance although I was on on division
two but nonetheless I enjoyed working on
finance
so anyway I'm here to uh testify in
support of uh House Bill 347 which
passed the policy uh committee as you
know it authorizes the Superior Court uh
the Supreme Court
um
after the governor makes the initial
nomination to establish a land-use
docket which would be responsible for uh
hearing uh which would appoint a judge
that's experienced in that area of the
law and would be responsible for hearing
all land use appeals throughout the
state it's sort of modeled as I as I
mentioned I think on the when I spoke on
the floor after the business court
docket example which has been in effect
for
probably close to 15 years now and
really has been very successful that
that docket again sort of consolidates
complex business cases uh before one
judge
um uh in Merrimack in Merrimack County
um although the judge can can travel to
other places if need be and that has
worked out very successfully I think if
you talk to the members of the bar or
the business Community they'd say that
that they think that's that's been a
success so
um you know this will this as everybody
knows I think we have a housing problem
in New Hampshire
this bill isn't going to be the Panacea
to solve the the uh the housing problem
but I think it will uh be a step in the
right direction and I think a pretty
significant step because one of the
things that that we've heard repeatedly
is that the time it takes for cases to
that are assigned to sort of the regular
docket to go uh the land use cases to be
resolved in the Superior Court can be
can take a long time and that is a real
discouragement for people uh who are you
know for developers and that kind of
thing so I think this will will uh
will help to alleviate that issue and
hopefully help to make more affordable
housing available throughout the state
and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
well since I'm on the bill is one of the
sponsors I'll let representative McGuire
share the discussion
well my ears perked up when you said the
words Merrimack County because three of
us on this committee are members of
America from Merrimack County so
um I guess we provide security for the
courts is this bill going to end up
costing our County something for for
more of that you know I don't think so
just because it's going to be um I mean
they'll you know there will be another
judge
well I mean if
arguably it could you know you could
have a sheriff's expense for another
another uh court officer to provide
security and you know I have to say I
said Merrimack County because that's
where the business Court typically sits
and it is a state capital it kind of
makes sense I suspect um and I know uh
Karen Gorham is here from the judicial
branch I suspect that what she would say
is although Merrimack County might be
the sort of default if it turns out that
there's you know they have more
courtroom available in some other County
assuming it's sort of generally in the
you know in the area where most of the
cases are arose there would not be no
reason they couldn't uh house the court
there but I I would tend to think
Merrimack County would be the default
oh because because you're a sponsor I
see you're sitting over there yes all
right thank you so
um
is this sized correctly I I guess I
assume that if there weren't the very
many land use cases or maybe this this
judge the backlog of land use cases went
away or something they would do other
Superior Court cases that's that's
correct um
again as with the business Court you
know judge McNamara judge McNamara was
the first business court judge and
served until he retired and I believe
judge Anderson is now taken over but my
understanding is that although judge
McNamara did mostly business cases there
were times when for one reason or
another you know the schedule was such
that he could do other things and I know
for example he tried some criminal cases
I suspect he may have tried some other
cases and I think that would be true in
the land you stock it also and it may
also be true that if you know at any
particular time there were like a whole
you know
and even more uh uh heavy load of land
use cases that uh chief justice Neto
would assign another judge to work with
you know with the land use judge to hear
those cases
one last one for me and then I'll ask
for others are land use cases somehow
seasonal I mean construction generally
doesn't happen as much during the winter
so do these kind of cases
I would say I would say in terms of like
when they're filed maybe although I I
can't say that for sure I think in terms
of you know when they end up when
hearings end up being held and the cases
uh adjudicated I would tend to say no
that's that generally is not the case
any other Representatives have questions
for
nope seeing none thank you great well
thank you very much
is there anyone else who would like to
give us some information about
um house bill 347. here we go okay
thank you Mr chair and Mr acting chair
my name is Karen Gorham I'm the superior
court administrator and I can assure you
representative McGuire it will not cost
Merrimack County any more money we have
managed to fully max out the Merrimack
County Superior Court there are three
courtrooms there and three full-time
judges so um if this bill comes to
fruition we would likely house the land
use docket at Hillsboro North Superior
Court in Manchester they have an extra
courtroom that is currently used just
for arraignments and we can hold those
elsewhere
we still have the Old Courthouse that
may not be fully yes all right thank you
I was part of that move that was an
interesting day
my reason for being here is I wanted to
clarify one thing that um that with
regard to the number of Judges that
we're asking for for the Superior Court
as you are probably all well aware we
had a weighted caseload study completed
in the judicial branch over the last two
years that weighted caseload study
indicated that we needed 2.5 more
Superior Court judges in our budget we
asked for one more Superior Court judge
if the land use docket passes and comes
into fruition we are not asking for a
second new judge it would be only the
land use Court Judge what that would
allow us to do is prioritize the land
use docket cases but as you correctly
pointed out representative McGuire the
statute also the land use docket statute
allows that judge to be assigned to any
other matters within the jurisdiction of
the superior court so by pulling the um
the complex civil case type of land use
docket cases from our judges around the
state adding a judge who will specialize
in this type of case we're pulling some
of the work from our local judges and we
would not need another one to fill that
position
um and that is really what I wanted to
clarify for you today that we're not
asking for a second new judge one new
judge overall
all right representative Sweeney has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you so
much for being here
will the filing fee to get in front of
this court be uniform across the border
will depend on development size
no the filing fee for all Superior Court
civil cases to file electronically which
all of our cases are is 280 that applies
to every type of case oftentimes in some
case types will get a motion to request
a waiver of a filing fee sometimes with
a restraining order usually not with
businesses and private attorneys but we
will get waivers to waive that fee but
other than that it's a flat fee 280
dollars
thank you
let me ask you about a related question
that we're dealing with here and that's
the board of tax and land appeals
so when someone has a has a dispute over
their property tax
assessment they have a choice of going
to Superior Court or the board of tax on
land appeals do you see do you know
how many go to Superior Court is it next
to none or is it it's a lot it's a lot
okay so a lot of our
um our our assessment appeals right now
deal with telecommunications companies
and we have cases going back
four four calendar years for for tax
years on these cases we get hundreds of
those every year we
um we consolidate all of those cases at
Merrimack Superior Court in front of one
judge the legal issue is the same in all
of those cases so I think what happened
in the past maybe if judgment is still
here no he might remember one of the
issues went on appeal to the Supreme
Court it applied to all 400 pending
cases and resolved a number of those
cases then another issue came up the
idea is to take one lead case get that
in front of the Supreme Court decide and
then hopefully resolve the other cases
so they're managed well most of our
cases are are the Telecommunications we
do not get a lot of
individual homeowners appealing the
assessment of their home we get a lot of
the the Telecommunications is this the
business judge that does that or is it
is not oh it is not so it's yet another
it's just a Consolidated case type
simply like we do with all of the YDC
claims that are coming in we've got
almost a thousand YDC cases right now
and so Superior Court we've Consolidated
those in front of one judge and have a
lead case that people file into there's
a few offshoot cases for those that were
sent to group homes that were not
managed by the state but most of those
cases are in front of one judge in
Rockingham Superior Court he was in
Merrimack where they all came in but he
thankfully took them with him when he
was assigned to Rockingham
I see thank you representative Sweeney
hey you just to follow up on that
the conversation we're now having what's
the backlog of land use cases compared
to the backlog of tax appeal cases I do
not have that number
um I I do not have that number I do know
that it's a it's considered a complex
civil case type there are a lot of
pleadings in land use cases there are a
lot of hearings to be held and sometimes
they can get backlogged behind the
criminal cases which have statutory
deadlines this bill the way I read it
gives gives statutory deadlines to these
cases and having the one dedicated judge
will allow them to move through without
getting behind our average caseload per
judge for calendar year 2022 was 900
cases
vast majority of them are criminal that
have to have their quick hearings and
Speedy trials well you appreciate it
anyone else
thank you very much thank you
anyone else wishing to speak on House
Bill 347.
all right I guess we'll close the here
so just a reminder for the division that
judicial branch will be healed you know
on Friday which we can discuss the
additional judge that time as well
all right gee we're doing really well
today
representative evil you're going to go
make more copies I assume okay thank you
so we'll be back here in 15 minutes
absolutely
but everybody
foreign
making an appropriation to the solid
waste management fund Etc representative
ebaugh thank you thank you very much to
uh the committee and to the chairman for
our continuing conversation uh of solid
waste so
um what this bill would do it does a
couple of things the first thing was
that that I should explain is that last
year
um the the legislature and the governor
signed in to affect the creation of a
solid waste management fund and the
solid waste management fund would be a
program whereby
municipalities and businesses could
participate in a matching grant program
that would continue in our quest to
reduce or better handle
Solid Waste in the state of New
Hampshire what this bill would do first
of all there there was a there was a
change that we wanted to expand the
sources of fund funds for the for the
fund because when it originally came
through last year the only source that
was identified was an EPA Grant and I
don't know if you guys know it um
there was a as part of the
infrastructure law there are EPA grants
that are available for recycling and
solid waste management
and everybody was super excited to be
able to use those funds but the
guidelines have come out and pursuant to
the guidelines States can't apply for
the infrastructure funds only towns and
businesses can and the base rate is 250
000 for a grant so it's you know
um it also I think just in the haste of
legislating
um we should have had a more expanded uh
source of funds and so that's that was
the main thing that the bill did and it
did um it did get amended because there
were a couple of grammatical errors so
the amendment doesn't I mean it wasn't a
really big deal any play anyway so the
bill came through the environment and
agriculture committee with a 20-zip uh
unanimous recommendation for passage it
passed on a Voice vote in the state I
mean in the in the house and so what I'm
here before you now to talk with you
about is the opportunity for the state
to appropriate money into the solid
waste management fund one other thing
that we did do as part of this bill is
it it connects up with um the goals that
are set forth in the in the management
plan and goals that have been identified
by the working group that we really want
to put forth the concept of concept uh
composting and food waste diversion as a
way of decrease seeing what's going into
our landfills and so actually at Senator
Howard Pearl's suggestion we tweaked the
language slightly to do a prioritization
for composting for the first couple of
years of the Appropriations existence
the fund is an again another mechanism
that a lot of other states use to try to
promote their Solid Waste diversion
within their within their states
and as I explained when we were talking
before
municipalities are kind of out there on
their own trying to figure things out
and they need some support for doing
their own planning and their own
planning is really like a pivotal part
of the whole state as a whole doing
better and putting in in making the
Solid Waste Management plan goals
work and really
um this is a partnership I think
amongst all you know between the
legislature and the governor and and our
agencies to really just try to rebuild
and do better with solid waste and our
municipalities are a really key part of
that and giving them some help through
this fund through a matching grant
program would be another really great
way to start and we do have a a des
letter I know they really like this idea
they tend to be not you know they tend
to make not take positions so much on
outside Appropriations but I think to
promote the partnership for all of us it
would be a good thing I again I just
want to reiterate that I'm I really hope
that we can get a broader conversation
going within the legislature focusing on
Source reduction
um and including pfas including all
sorts of things that are going into our
landfills we have to deal with the
landfill leachate it has a lot of toxics
in it that end up in our wastewater
treatment plants we have to test for the
toxics we have to suck them back out and
they have to go back in the landfill and
uh you know
I really think that if we can help our
towns and businesses do better from the
front end we'll all benefit in the long
run and it will promote uh business I
know a lot of businesses have been
interested in this
so
questions for representative evil sure
Mr McGuire thank you Mr chairman
um let's talk about line seven
so if I read this correctly this is
removing the fiscal committee from the
process of accepting such grants is that
correct
I think it was the executive Council
the executive or was it or was it the
fit I left my bill over there sorry a
little discombobulated here all right
Mr Hoffman Melissa and he yes or maybe
both right it would allow the
the department to accept funds directly
in without going through government
Council and fiscal committee as long as
they're used for that specific purpose
I see so
um yes so let me push back on this
because the fiscal committee and the
executive Council exist for very
important reasons which is when people
give us money there very often our
strings attached and and we can't allow
an agency to to make a decision that
obligates the state in some way
without the legislators and the approval
right and and and the executive Council
I guess in some cases so so I I would
object to to this particular section
okay well I think the idea there was to
to streamline the process but I
certainly understand where you're coming
from and if that stood in the way of
moving the fund forward you'd get no
objection from me and may I continue
yeah so let's talk about the the funds
do you know if the governor has has
asked for any funds like this uh section
two I do not believe that he he has
again the
um you know the bill has been brought
forward very very late in the in the
process and the law as it existed
um it only was the fund was able to
accept funds from the EPA so this
amendment was necessary to expand that I
will tell you that I've approached the
governor's office and I've opened up the
conversation about that
I I'm not sure
I'm not going to speak for them it
didn't sound to me like they would have
an objection I think they're they're
very
um interested in the subject of solid
waste as a general matter I mean we
certainly have been talking about this
issue of landfills and and I I just like
to talk about that a little bit there's
a general
sense that New Hampshire actually for
its own trash we have we have adequate
capacity and as we now know about half
of the trash that goes into private
landfills comes from out of state
we can't really block that but what we
can do is do better in protecting our
own capacity and one of the ways to
protect our capacity is simply to put
less trash in our landfills
um
I think that should be a societal goal
if I can say that I mean if you're a
Yankee you don't really want to be
throwing everything
um away and you know as I said
the the back side of it the the
landfills that exist are pretty much
with us forever and yes they have Clay
lining yes they are monitored you know
over a period of time they can leak
um and this leachate that comes out of
them is pretty much of a toxic stew that
we've got to deal with and if I mean I
was thinking about this last night if
we're half of the trash that's coming
into our state is from out of state
we're dealing with the leachate that is
coming
right so anyway we need to divert as
much as we can
see no further oh I'm sorry
I'd just like to say that I share
representative why is concerns
I don't think we should be bypassing
either the governor's Council or the
fiscal committee
all right thank you very much
so just far okay
just to follow up on that fiscal
committee review where did that come
from was that the sponsors or did the
Des suggest that removing the governor's
Council and the fiscal committee
I worked with the LBA and we discussed
about we discussed it and we thought
that to simplify the process that might
be a way to go but I'm not gonna I mean
you know it's it's my bill Des I won't I
won't say that they put that in there
this was something in my um
desire to streamline the process that
that uh I thought about and that that I
that I did so I take full responsibility
for it I wasn't trying to dodge anything
I was just thinking that you know in the
in the overall scheme of things it would
be helpful to try to get our money to
our towns and businesses that's really
it
Mr Hoffman
I can tell you that I suggested that
when uh I worked with representative
Abel on this bill because the money for
that fund is for very specific purpose
unlike many things where you can get a
grant and use them for various things
and there's a decision on how to use the
money but I also understand the concerns
of not having fiscal committee review it
thank you very much I'm sure chairman
Weiler is chair of the fiscal committee
would probably would like to see less
work but we also in
we also enjoy being thorough but thanks
very much for your testimony
representative Mooney nice to see you
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
to members of the committee for the
record I am Maureen Mooney I represent
the town of Merrimack and Hillsborough
District 12. unfortunately my community
has seen firsthand and has been deeply
affected by pfas evidence shows it's
spreading everywhere even to our waste
water into our landfills
every dollar counts every dollar counts
and counteracting pfas and where it may
spread next so I would just recommend
that this division recommend to the full
finance committee that we broaden the
funding sources for Des to explore this
chemical thank you all for your time
thank you any questions for the
representative from Merrimack right is
that Hillsborough 12 or Hillsborough 12
now trying to learn them all I still
haven't figured out McGuire's District
but representative McGuire
he is Merrimack I believe right what
county mayor yeah all right let me ask a
question no I don't want to ask a
question
representative evil
very much for being
say that the municipalities are under
extreme extreme stress trying to deal
with the Avalanche of waste coming their
way much of which includes toxic
chemicals including pfas
yes I would I've referred to this issue
as a prism there are just so many sides
so many areas between air groundwater
Wastewater and the like I mean it's
coming up on these municipalities
without any warning or any preparation
it's just there so any help at all is a
certainly welcomed and would lessen that
strain
any further questions
representative Weiler thank you Mr
chairman do you think there's one
particular source that you could
identify where this pfas is coming from
we have in our town
a company called cincobain
in 2016 as a Plastics Company with its
base in Paris France
it was discovered that P they were
emitting pfas
and from that point forward it has been
explosive
so though I am not a scientist or an
investigator it is my understanding that
Saint gobane is clearly at the center of
this
well thank you representative Mooney I
know that you've worked very hard on
that issue and Merrimack and been
leading the fight with some of your
other Representatives but you've really
drawn attention to it you should be
thanked for that
I appreciate that thank you
on behalf of the town of Merrimack not
the county of Merrimack town of
Merrimack yeah he I think representative
McGuire wants to set you straight now no
I I want to bring up something I I was
reading in the bill and based on your
experience on finance
um so this bill allocates money in a
kind of an odd way and which is it's a
legislative special it takes money from
the current biennium not next biennium
right and it saves it and pays it out
over four years now do you think this
issue
ought to be simply funded in a budget so
much per year
maybe add infant item or just for
current budget or is do you like this
particular way that it's that it's
funding
thank you for the question certainly
open to different ways of funding my
interest is looking out for the
community the health and safety and
Welfare of not only my community
Merrimack but the surrounding
communities that pfas has so quickly
spread to since it was discovered at
Saint Cobain in 2016. so I um I don't
want to say that I'm against the funding
mechanism or that I would be opposed to
other options for a funding mechanism I
would leave that to this to the division
so you're suggesting representative
McGuire that we would set aside the 20
and 24th the 68
000 and 25 the 556 versus taking it all
out on the head end
yeah I mean that seems to make more
sense in terms of how we budget things
like that all right good point
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you for just kind of
follow off that conversation
are there projects that Merrimack wants
to do today to
to utilize These funds that we can't you
have the project for so just waiting
till fiscal year 25 work for Merrimack
or does Merrimack can Merrimack start
the project next this summer if we were
to authorize it
all good questions and you know
interestingly enough we lost our uh
excellent exceptional Wastewater Plant
manager she got another job she was Top
Notch at this and it's no wonder
everybody probably wanted to have her
work for them she would be better posed
or the person who took her place would
be bet in a better position to answer
that but I can tell you that there will
always be projects I can think of one
right now very pressing that's not
necessarily related to waste water but
very pressing in Merrimack and I'm sure
there would be others so I would say
bottom line of your answer is it will be
a welcomed arrival the funding mechanism
the sooner the better
further question no good
all right so you know further questions
you're always welcome here
um
I guess that's it unless the folks from
Des you have anything to add
thank you Mr chair your name for the
record please my name is Michael Nork
with the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services Solid Waste
Management Bureau
um
what what I'm going to say is that we
strongly support the intent of the solid
waste management fund and uh the idea
that that can be used to help
municipalities and entities within the
state to reduce
disposal of waste and landfills and
incinerators and and you know encourage
more preferable use of those those
materials as resources rather than as
wastes through recycling through
composting and we also strongly support
um the bill here the HP 462's intention
to prioritize uh use of funds to divert
food waste because it ties into the bill
that the committee had considered
earlier on HP 300 which was to again
encourage disposal or diversion of food
waste so this is another way to tackle
the issue through giving grants to
municipalities and to other entities
that can engage in projects to either
develop infrastructure for management of
food waste or projects to you know
divert food from schools or businesses
um
so so with all that being said we have
we strongly support the intent here we
do have to be agnostic as to the the
policy around where that funding comes
from and that's what this bill is is
really that's that's obviously the Crux
of the build 200 the 2 million dollar uh
appropriation to the fund
um and as representative people noted
that fund was created last year and to
date no funds have actually been
appropriated to that fund so so we're
not actually able to enact the intention
of that bill or that that fund
um
I guess with that I'm happy to take any
questions the committee might have
questions
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman you heard what representative
Mooney said
is she a little confused about this bill
because her issue was about waste water
and this is about solid waste does does
waste that comes out of Wastewater
plants turn into solid waste and then
get you get into landfills or are they
or these two separate issues kind of
that is a great question um so there is
a little bit of confusion I think in in
general in terms of how Wastewater and
solid waste are regulated and at DES we
have separate programs under separate
statutes
um to to regulate those separately but
there is definitely some overlap with
Wastewater when it comes to the solids
that are extracted from a wastewater
treatment plant that often do get sent
to landfills for disposal so so there is
a little bit of overlap but to my
knowledge the intent here
with HB 462 and the solid waste
management fund that was created last
session the intent there was really to
focus on Solid Waste Management
and not necessarily the waste water
management side of things that's just my
understanding but um I I could be
incorrect on that
isn't there a place like a point where
they those two items intersect in other
words Solid Waste has a direct impact on
the wastewater treatment I think I heard
that somewhere in The Testament P fast
as an example so maybe that's what's
being alluded to and needs to be
addressed
that's a good point representative hatch
thank you for the question
um yeah again the the
as a society we use products we consume
products we dispose of products um so
there are multiple points of
intersection I think that that you raise
a good point that the products that we
consume and use and ultimately some of
that can end up in in Wastewater in one
form or another or
chemical components of it could end up
in Wastewater so there is certainly some
overlap
correct
so I have a question of funding
we received a number of settlements from
air quality groundwater pollution
are there any funds out there because I
know that the department takes no
position with respect to the source of
any future appropriation might there be
another source I don't like to put the
department on record of being supportive
of a different Source but there must is
there's something else out there that
could be used to fund this versus
General funds
that's a great question
um I not I'm not aware of of specific
sources of funding uh except to say that
there there might be future grant
opportunities uh through federal
agencies uh like like was discussed when
representative evil introduced Bill last
session there was some understanding
that the EPA might provide funding that
then could be funneled into this fund we
later found out after that that
opportunity was kind of finalized that
they there wasn't going to be that
possibility so
yeah it's hard to really know but I
think there could be potential
opportunities through federal agencies
or other
state programs I think obviously General
funds tend to be the one that most
people can think of readily but uh
I I don't know I guess is the short
answer yeah maybe if going back to Mike
winsett to see what is out there
representative Wilder and I serve on
fiscal and we see hundreds of millions
of dollars often each month coming in
from the federal government for a
variety of of things and from a variety
of federal sources so I would hope that
maybe something was out there but that's
a great Point yeah there's been a lot of
focus from from federal programs on
brownfields on like arpa funding for
Wastewater
um to date there hasn't been a lot of
focus from the feds on on Solid Waste
Management that has traditionally been
up to the states to to fund and
Implement so that's that's part of the
challenge I think for so long that there
hasn't been really a focus on this
particular area
all right thank you uh seeing no further
questions again thanks we'll close the
work session and see you I'm sorry
representative evil
I'm sorry but I noticed there was
someone from the municipal Association
here and I didn't know if they had any
thing that they wanted to add to the
conversation
I think she's been taking notes but
you're welcome to speak in the
if
Catherine heck
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee my name is
Catherine heck for the record and I
represent the municipal Association and
we do support this legislation our
members have a policy that we support
programs that would allow municipalities
to reduce solid waste recycle reuse and
of course composting and other measures
while maintaining any local control and
of course we do know that food waste
makes up about 20 to 25 percent of what
is currently going into our transfer
station so these funds would become
extremely important for our
municipalities to move forward some of
their policy priorities and reducing
Solid Waste
seeing no further questions uh see you
at 1
this afternoon
foreign
see information security officer for the
Department of Information Technology
so I guess
I don't see a sponsor
would you like to speak to this
commissioner
I think everybody knows you but just for
the record for those watching you're
right good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee uh my name is Dennis
Goulet I'm the commissioner for the
Department of Information Technology and
uh representative Edwards sponsored this
bill at my request so we actually when
when it was introduced we sat together
to introduce it
and so
the state has had a chief information
security officer in place for over a
decade
so we're not asking to fund anything
here even though it did have a FN
attached to what I sent
in a zero dollar fiscal note for this
um essentially what this is doing is
codifying what we're already doing in in
statute and also making it so so I'm not
worried that I'm going to keep a
security officer function running and I
I know how important it is but you know
for continuity I think you know the
National Association of State Chief
Information officers has voted 12 years
running that the cyber security was the
number one priority so I think we want
to make sure that we we have that in
place and and duties and
responsibilities and Authority defines
that's simply the the objective
and I believe you spoke to this when you
presented your budget if my memory
serves me correctly right I did
presentation yep
any questions of the commissioner
look at anybody left
so this person will have the same
unclassified level or whatever that they
have now that's correct they're they're
unclassified and they we set their
compensation through the jcec I think
maybe three years ago
so
it's all all the administrative
associated with it is done
so this would appear to be something
that we could actually vote on and move
along so we show a little progress I
move on to patch is it seconded
represents Sweeney's
okay
representative Maguire
yeah
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrells yes
put some patches in here representative
Hewitt yes
the clerk votes I and the chair
okay all right
uh one two three four five six seven in
favor and no names
all right
we are moving things through
so the emotion offered by representative
McGuire passes seven to zero
another blurb for you the rights of
committee I might as well do it now yeah
this is easy we got to have 20 minutes
yeah
all right well moving right along we'll
take a 20 minute break
well as as it was originally introduced
however we do have some concerns with
um how it was amended it's amending
again the municipal Pace statute under
our current Municipal pay statute which
is uh RSA 53f
um it allows lender consent
um and uh all lien holders if a property
owner wants to move forward with this
all lien holders have to sign off on it
in order for it to become a priority
lien that is found on RSA 53 F5
um
however and that that part of the
statute hasn't been hasn't been amended
um however uh F uh eight has been
amended and it strikes the language
um that references the lender consent
and this is concerning to us because you
know while the intent is for C Pace it
again is amending the municipal pay
statute and our concern with this is the
impact that it could have on the
secondary Market if you were to look up
at Fannie Mae and their guide guidelines
on selling you know or or types of
properties their mortgages they'll buy
they will not buy from a bank or acquire
from a bank a mortgage that has a pace
assessment attached to it a six-month or
excuse me a pace assessment attached to
it and a lot of our banks bundle
mortgages sell off to the secondary
market and maintain the servicing rights
so again while we don't have a um we
don't have a a a position on the
underlying build them how it was amended
we do have a slight concern we do
appreciate the sponsor was uh did it
when it was amended it keeps the
um it keeps the assessment with the
property however again the concern that
we do have is the fact that it does
strike that language and create a
priority lien I've provided the sponsor
uh with some suggested language that
just reinstates that consent Language by
adding it to the last sentence
um I provide a few folks on the on the
um on the sub on the committee uh with
this language I'm happy to again I got a
couple more copies I'm happy to hand out
but again it just on page two lines 9
through 12 just adding
um adding on to that sentence uh to
state except that all prior recorded
mortgages or liens shall be shall retain
priority over the lien of assessment
contract unless all such mortgages lien
holes of record have consented to the
lien as provided and again it references
RSA 53 F5
so I'm happy to take any questions any
of the committee members have
president McGuire so
um I'm hoping you can answer questions
not just on the banking part but on the
actual what's going on here yeah so is
this
um loans made to property owners in this
case commercial property owners to add
solar power and things like that to
their property that's my understanding
yes okay yeah and and for follow-up so
so and the the source of funds for these
loans is the department is the federal
department of U.S department of energy I
I believe that this is the U.S
department of energy has um you know
guidelines but it would be private
investors from my understanding is the
way it would work it would be private
Capital
um
okay and so follow so so but the state
is guaranteeing these loans in some way
or so it would be the municipality
through the tax assessment would I I'm
sorry I don't
I don't believe I'm not sure I think
that would be a question for the sponsor
I'm not sure if there's that mechanism
as a state guaranteeing those loans but
but there's a lien placed on the
property yes right so that if they're
not paid back you could seize the
property and sell it that way yes yeah
so there would be and that's that's the
you know the kind of the the basis of
our concerns is the additional lien for
that special assessment for that
commercial
um but you know by taking away our kind
of um our consent rights
um you know I think there could be
situations where they would be inclined
to I mean with Rising energy costs one
two it could increase the value of the
property if it was a if it was a risk
that at the time they're worth taking on
again so you have the C Pace but then
you also have the pace and you know our
our basis of our concerns is it's also
addressing the residential Municipal
Pace as well okay one last question so
so your main concern is which loan is
senior yes you want the mortgage loan to
be the senior loan and the this loan to
be junior to that yes yes correct okay
great thank you
further questions representative Griffin
as as I read this it's a
it looks like we're mandating
that the local tax collector
Services loan basically
correct it would be it the way it works
is it would be again that special
assessment would be applied to the you
know it would be registered I believe in
the register of deeds it'd be uh paid
through their the tax collection as a
special assessment
I was I understand that
state laws we the state would be
responsible for the cause that involved
in that
it would appear it would appear
this is probably not a question for you
sir but maybe Mr Hoffman is there any
reason this didn't go to a second
committee before coming here like calm
Congress perhaps
sure
amended Tuesday
all right
yeah and so we're still awaiting a
number of folks so we haven't received
anything from the Department of energy
um
treasury
Revenue Administration
as it's amended
um I think we only would need to hear
from the municipal Association and they
have provided something we just haven't
had time to put it into a fiscal number
yet oh okay
perhaps we got the bill a little quickly
and missed some of the oversight
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here to
answer the questions
um so your proposed uh fix here to the
issue that you guys see is this not the
way that the organization that supports
Pace nationally wants this policy
implemented correct my understanding is
the organization CP C Pace Alliance um
you know consent is is should be a part
of an eec pays program thank you welcome
thank you for the question
further questions comments yes
representing Kimbrell's thank you Mr
chair I'm not sure if maybe you were
present does anybody know what the vote
was in the science and technology and
energy committee and then and then
furthermore what it was in the house
uh so
so it was I want to say 17 3 or 15-5 out
of committee and it was a Voice vote in
the house and uh was that OTP or it OTP
as amended thank you you're welcome
thank you
you didn't happen to contact uh the
chair right into the chair of science
and technology did you or I ran upstairs
um they were stolen in committee
um in a hearing
representative evil thank you is this
enabling legislation so that a
municipality or can do this if they want
to so there was some discussion about a
mandate but it it really is up to a
district or a municipality whether they
want to pursue this is that right that
is my understanding that it's a it's
enabling the and I think you know
represented from the municipality could
speak to from the municipal Association
but it's my understanding that this is
enabling a municipality would have to
choose I believe right now
believe Dover and Nashua I want to say
are current Pace municipalities
um so but yeah I believe that's the way
it works
thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
very much thank you very much take care
Catherine heck please
thank you chairman leishman and
representatives I appreciate the
opportunity to speak on this bill
um my name is Catherine heck for the
record and I represent the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and we did write a
fiscal note both for the introduced Bill
and for the amended bill as well which
does not change the fiscal note very
much I am not an expert in Pace see Pace
or our pace which are all energy
programs however I did do extensive
research on this bill in particular so
yes it is enabling legislation currently
we have two communities Nashua and
Durham that are involved in a c Pace or
our PACE program and a little bit of
history is that this legislation was
enacted in 2010 by New Hampshire
authorizing or enabling
cities towns and Village districts to
establish Energy Efficiency in clean
energy districts under 53f so it allowed
them to create these districts and
incurred debt through issuing Municipal
revenue bonds for qualified energy
conservation projects
but however in 2015 the legislature
amended Pace legislation and removed the
authority of municipalities to provide
financing so it could only be done
through private investors
so that
um did change how of course these
projects could be financed now this
particular bill as amended I think the
reason why
um it might be here is because at one
point the state treasurer was involved
and the bill was kind of
um complex and it's in its strategy I I
guess I would say
um so we did work with the sponsor a bit
to condense the bill and just make it
enabling legislation I do not believe
there's any fiscal impact to the state
as it's going to the municipalities
issuing these revenue bonds however it
is unclear how this legislation will
impact local expenditures because we
don't know how many municipalities will
adopt it and of course it does require
the municipality to take on debt and of
course there is that payback of course
where the bank would be the senior lien
holder if reamended and the municipality
would be the junior lien holder so again
there's no guarantee however we know 38
states have these programs and it has
been successful in these states in
bringing forward More Energy Efficiency
so we don't have any position on the the
policy however we can't speak to what
the local impact would be should in
municipality take this on and if the
commercial property default and what
that would cost but again I think that's
a local a local issue but there has been
great success Nationwide
so I can certainly try to take questions
but I am not a pace expert by any
stretch of the imagination
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here and
sorry without the sponsor here
um since you did say that you helped
work on the legislation I imagine in
Science and Tech
was the striking out of the current
policy within terms of lien holding was
that an intentional change or was that
an accidental pickup so we did want to
work with the bankers Association to
make sure that
um this could be completely enacted and
make sure that there would be no issues
with banking Freddie may you know
Freddie Mac all of that I think there's
been some history in the bankers
Association can come back up and speak
to that and some of these programs were
affected by not having the correct
terminology and not having the correct
order of lean in it but it was a little
bit of a
quick turnaround to try to get
legislation that enabled municipalities
to move forward their policy priorities
and the Energy Efficiency World well
combining it with the bill that we were
originally presented with so I think
that peace was left out but we're
certainly open to adding that because I
think that's really important
moving forward thank you you're welcome
representative Sweeney would you like to
perhaps work with the bankers group and
chairman Bose from Science and
Technology maybe bring this issue around
for us
okay thank you
representative McGuire I'm sorry thank
you
so I've heard two things just now that
that seem in Conflict one was that the
money and that's being lent is private
and one that it's towns taking on debt
so which is a
it can be a it will be able to be a
combination of both together or each one
separately under this legislation
depending on how it is structured under
53f so at this time the current law only
allows it to be a private investor and
the municipality is completely removed
from that the Miss penalty could partner
and do a P3 public-private partnership
and maybe get Summer part of that
funding or municipality can issue all of
the debt and take on all of the debt
um that used to be in legislation prior
to 2015 is my understanding of how it
would work but I am not an expert
currently it's private lenders correct
yes but somehow the municipality is
involved because they own the lien on
the on well they assess the property for
something larger than it would be
otherwise collect the payments in tax
and then forward those payments to the
private lender is that right no no
there's no there's no forwarding of any
pain all right
there's no no forwarding of any any
payments unless they're and then the
whole foreclosure process is its own
special and unique process should
anything like that occur that's a whole
separate issue from this program it's
from this program and how it would work
this is to actually move forward putting
on the solar panels and More Energy
Efficiency in those larger commercial
units I believe it's five five or more
four four
yeah so yeah
um again I'm not an expert in this this
program unfortunately I did try to learn
a whole lot about it
um
and energy New Hampshire might be
another place to reach out to
um they didn't get back to us when we
tried to
work on this legislation though
well one question to ask is
um how is this better than
just simply someone purchasing solar
panels from a vendor and paying them
back over time right because you know
you buy stuff like a car or something
and you pay back over time and and the
vendor themselves arranges financing I
don't I don't see why the towns or
whoever is or us is involved
I would believe yes my understanding is
that if there's not the pub the private
partnership availability that the town
becomes the partner to move that policy
forward the town itself becomes the
partner rather than waiting for a
private entity to come in and become the
partner
so that's my understanding there is a
very successful story out of Virginia
for a community doing this and really
did a whole lot of green work this way
and reduced all their energy costs town
wide and did all this wonderful stuff
using this mod this model but this is
modified of course for New Hampshire
all right thank you I so much you'd be
happy to work with representative
Sweeney and the bankers and try to work
something through absolutely I I did
briefly look at the language and over a
brief look that's it's right on point
with what we had already discussed so
thank you very much for allowing me to
speak very uneducatedly about this time
now your wealth of information as always
thanks
seeing no further questions anyone
I'm sure you enjoy your new assignment
yeah I'm very good
thank you very much
all right we have agriculture coming in
at two so
should be
the former speaker and now commissioner
of the Department of Agriculture
nice to see you Mr Speaker
it is good to be here Mr chairman
members of the committee
and I think everybody knows you but we
don't know your associate so Michelle uh
Tebow is my Administrative Assistant she
does all the heavy lifting when it comes
to the budget all right I'm glad you're
still so honest
all right thanks
all set so you just
well we we really didn't bring any
handouts
um there's really only one thing in the
governor's
um
recommendation that we do want to to
talk about we're glad to answer any
questions or the the the main thing in
the budget for me is finally having made
it this far with an assistant
commissioner
I think I'm probably the only
Commissioner of a department with over
40 people that doesn't have an assistant
have a a deputy who's the state
veterinarian who's busier than I am so
that really doesn't provide any
administrative support I had intended to
ask for uh for an assistant
a couple budgets ago and a couple things
came up and then the pandemic came up
and so here we are and um
that's in there last year the
legislature approved an invasive species
program to try to eradicate eradicate
the plant invasive species that we're
seeing all over the state they put in a
coordinator I should say the legislature
approved a coordinator position with no
money so this year we've asked for the
funding for the previously approved
position
the thing that has created a little bit
of consternation for us and I don't know
if you're
pages are the same as ours on the
governor's budget but it was age
yeah all right so it'd be page 250
sex that we would be looking at
so for
many years going back in history there
was a
um
contract
coordinator for the state Conservation
Commission
there were some problems my
understanding is with that individual
and they ended the contract never did
anything and so then the the 10
districts that make up the state
Conservation Commission obviously the I
shouldn't say Obviously but they are
made up of the ten counties were sort of
floundering with no coordination
in the last budget we did move get that
move to a part-time position
we have a great individual in there it's
been well well established that this is
worthy of full-time and the person that
we have won't be staying with us if we
don't get this to a full-time position
or will we ever have anybody long term
in all likelihood
and what happened was well wait a minute
maybe it wasn't you shuffled
I shuffled my pages around so
what did I do
that's in my stack here but I can
basically I'll let her look for that
sorry about that but what happened we
had forty thousand dollars in for the
part-time position continuing and then
small amount of the benefits that go
along with that we requested the
full-time position
so we had taken out the part-time
position
and then the governor took out
the full amount so now we're left with
nobody
in this budget
um
we have a revolving fund
this the total cost is 93 000 with
Benefits it's 56 I think in salary the
first year and then the rest in in
benefits
and um
the conservation fund can fund this
position thank you
and so while we were
hoping that the general fund would
um Pitch in on this there is there are
adequate funds in there to sustain this
for a while most of the money is given
out in Grants
the conservation districts for products
such as stream restoration any number of
things is generally three to four
hundred thousand dollars that's given
out a year the fund has about 1.2 in it
right now
um
and so I would highly recommend and ask
that this position be restored
unfortunately I haven't had the
opportunity to talk to anybody in the
governor's office because I was gone
last week
and I had requested previous to have a
conversation but
um that was before the governor's budget
was submitted so maybe talking a little
out of school but this is my opportunity
to to do the ask and to do it without
general fund dollars
um to fund that position
restore it to the budget
to our budget request
any thoughts uh members
yes represent evil
I was trying to welcome and good to see
you I was just trying to um
to figure this out so the first thing is
that you would like to have an assistant
commissioner because you haven't had one
and did you say I'm sorry I don't I'm
taking notes I don't have my book so is
the was the funding put in for this okay
yes both of the the two previous
positions are funded this one was not
but it it actually moved backwards okay
and then you
how does the invasive species program
work under agriculture because I know
Des is also responsible for invasive
species or how
I'm not sure what what they do we work
on eradication we have a person who's
devoted part of his time to doing this
and odion park is a prime example of
some of the is one of the projects where
he's he's worked now this is always in
collaboration with others usually it can
be local conservation commissions can be
the state highway department local
Highway departments
any organization that may be
interested in in cleaning out an area of
invasive species and in the past we have
worked well with DOT on roadside but
we're losing the battle and this is his
part-time job there was a fund
established I think with a hundred and
fifty thousand to give out grants to
various communities
but they also need the education we need
somebody in this position full-time who
can be devoting their time to dealing
with this if you've ever been down to
Hartford Connecticut you've seen the
areas where you think you may be in a
foreign jungle
that's what we're going to look like if
we don't if we don't take this seriously
so okay I think I so I think Des
responsible for invasive
steps in water that is right this is
simply you're responsible for what's on
on the on the land yes and you have a
coordinate
well that's not his title he's an
inspector he is sort of because he's
passionate about it he's taken on a lot
of the responsibilities of trying to uh
to deal with this
and we want somebody who will focus on
this full-time
and what's the funding situation on that
that is General funds that's Jim
I was just trying to unwind everything
here so there's the state conservation
districts and then you had a coordinator
who was part-time but that position has
been removed and there's no funding
apparently story right yeah if you're if
if you're on page 256 and you you see
um
cost center 50 Personnel Service
temporary appointee and there's 40 462.
and then you follow that across there's
no money there
so what the governor and the budget here
we had requested
it in cost center 10.
and they took that out but not realizing
that they were then totally defunding
the position oh
so I think you know and that's very
understandable with the amount of work
they have to do and the time they have
to do it in so
um
that it that's the issue there and I
would point out to the uh to the
committee that the Department of
Agriculture if you take out
the some of the grants that we have such
as for
um land conservation maybe even within
that
we're cash positive we produce more
revenue for the state than we spent
to the tune of anywhere from two hundred
thousand to a million dollars a year
so we are not a drain on the on the
general fund
that's why I was hoping this money could
come from from the general fund so that
there'd be money available for the
grants but it is important to all the
districts everybody really has
appreciated over the last year and a
half that this individual has been on
what a different has been making in
coordinating the works of the 10
districts because without an executive
director the state Conservation
Commission
well largely
um
you know doesn't have a center doesn't
have that coordination that is so
important something of this size
represent Griffin followed by
representative Kim brawls thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um so where are you proposing this money
comes from
I I would say that if you do not wish to
give it to us from the general fund it
can come from the uh from that fund and
I have messed up my paperwork the
accounting unit on that
is soil conservation uh fund it's a
revolving fund
and uh
yeah
and it has about 1.2 million in it at
the moment
so
so I'm looking at page 256 what line
reflects that fund well it
it doesn't be increased well when when
you go to estimated source of funds it's
not broken down
here but it's other funds yep that's
where the money would come from I can't
tell you I understand how these things
work because they certainly are nothing
like a municipal budget so
never quite figured this this States out
excuse me we're still trying ourselves
yeah so but that is where I'm sure LBA
knows how to do that
representative Kimbrell's
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question
um you mentioned your typically net
positive in terms of money coming in
what are your sources of revenue so
largely the main sources of revenue we
have are from pesticides licensing so
every pesticides product that is used in
the state has to be registered with the
state I think right now 75 percent of
that fund stays in a revolving fund 25
goes to general fund
we have a
product registration on the animal
uh products if you pet foods and Grains
fertilizers lime any of those things
that are registered also have a fee that
come in and I think currently that's a
50 50 split I think there's a bill in
the works to change that not one that we
had had requested but
um
make things a lot less convoluted
although
I'm not the biggest fan of revolving
funds myself but um
they certainly have served this
department
well and they do stay within the areas
to support the department so can I have
a follow-up question uh and yes um I'm
very familiar with invasive species in
the water because I'm on a Lincoln
Association what what um what invasive
species in particular are on the land
that we're seeing um Bittersweet is in
my opinion one of the worst because it's
strangling off the trees and killing
them
um then we have the Japanese knotweed
which is just ever expanding uh we see
that all over the place in fields and on
the sides of the highways uh tree of
Heaven which I am not terribly familiar
with myself but that is also what the um
spotted a lanternfly
likes to um
feed off of and and that is a problem
for primarily for the grapes that's that
thing has been coming in we've been
doing a pretty good job of keeping it
out at this at this point by Nursery
inspections because that's primarily how
it comes in but that's a real problem
and it's a growing problem
um in Pennsylvania and the surrounding
areas it's not officially here yet but
if we can eliminate that it's host that
will help in the long term
okay
oh sorry so if someone wanted assistance
from your department to deal with uh in
eradication of invasive species how how
would they go about it well they would
contact
UM plan industry we don't do work on
private property
we do give them
the education we give them the advice
they need to do that themselves
so primarily we're working on on state
land Town state land right of ways
things like that but our advising in
those areas we do I think have the
ability in certain cases probably to
make a declaration and go on to private
property if it is
um
something that is extremely
extreme concern I'm not aware that we've
done that and I'm not a hundred percent
sure on that it's just something
rattling around in the back of my head
about that if we find somebody who isn't
cooperative
no just to comment um I I have my son
lives in New York and they have the tree
of Heaven there and it's just taking
over all the trees yeah
terrible
yes and that's this is a huge a huge
concern and we we need to do more in the
area of Education largely these are
going to be projects that one person is
not going to to do by himself and
rehearsal going to be working with
conservation
commissions districts to to really get
push that information out there and
hopefully as a as a team we'll be able
to to make a difference
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you commissioner for
being here uh this morning we had a work
session on HB 230 from representative
Bixby for an electronic data processing
system for all registrations under your
purview is that funding included in the
budget or is it something you would
support no that is that's a separate
bill it's not in in the budget and
it will allow us to do more of what
we're supposed to be be doing
um my joke has been by the time I'm done
being commissioner I want to bring us
into the 1990s
but hopefully with that bill and others
we'll actually get into the 21st century
the amount of man hours that we are
spending
bringing in the physical paperwork and
then entering it into programs is
mind-boggling and frankly you know we do
have well underway the animal database
which was approved some years ago and is
actually
um we will be awarding a bid on that
hopefully by about July 1st God knows
how long it'll take to develop it but
this is for the the other programs that
we need weights and measures has been a
real disaster that was literally the one
developed in the 80s by a sex offender
at the state prison
and we don't have the source code so if
you go any place that has a license for
weights and measures you'll notice
there's a sticker with my name on it
over former commissioner Merrills
name because nobody can get into the
system and actually change her name to
mine
that's how bad it is
so so I take it you're supportive of hpg
absolutely thank you
and just a follow-up to representative
Sweeney's question the fiscal note
indicates there's no General funds to
support this system
we currently don't have no
okay
we didn't know what we didn't know until
we finally had somebody from doit
embedded into the department
you know I I came into it new assuming
okay doit is looking out for our needs
and we'll be somewhere in the cube
once we got somebody to manage the
database we realized nobody was really
looking out for our our needs and we had
to be our own advocates
which we were with the database but uh
certainly been an eye-opening experience
with
what has so far been a failed
replacement system for weights and
measures
so we are well behind the eight ball
any further questions of the
commissioner
any questions representative McGuire
I guess seeing none of the division have
a
reference and what we do with the
agricultural budget
except it is presented with that fact
that we may have to make some changes
once we get the numbers for
the revenues
I guess you don't have to come back
commissioner and we'll we'll act on uh
House Bill 230 at some point as well all
right thank you very much appreciate
your time
and your service and all the long hours
that await you moving forward
Mr Hoffman could you get together with
the commissioner and staff as far as a
specific language for that uh position
that won't be funded with General funds
make a footnote somewhere
I have the information from the agency
requests okay I have everything I need
if the division chooses to add it
all right put it right in hospital one
okay thanks
thank you sir thanks thank you
so as a reminder to the division we have
a joint session with division three at 2
30.
so
I guess be prepared for something
in the main room yet
I don't believe they did
Could You Reach Out Mr Hoffman to doit
and
see if they've weighed in on House Bill
230.
thanks
since it's a doit issue for sure
all right thanks